if you want to see all the sides of Rome
you'll need plenty of time this city has
over 2700 years of history and that's
evident wherever you look
art historian Valerio van AZ is a tour
guide in Rome his company Roma mihrab
Elia offers tours on Vespa scooters ok
these typical Italian scooters are ideal
for weaving through the heavy traffic in
Rome we pass all the main sights like
the Colosseum which dates back to around
ad 80 there are two things I like about
driving a Vespa around Rome first I like
the sound of the engine it's been second
I realized how many beautiful places
there are past the Castel Sant'Angelo
and st. Peter's Basilica through all the
little streets and past the fountains
and I think Rome is fantastic meant that
he could own a fantastic
one place where Valerio Venezia always
stops is the Capitoline hill home to the
capital line museums
Samuel s so sue Lafayette circum we're
on the piazza de Campidoglio we were
various topics coming together there is
the era of Michelangelo and then ancient
Rome with the statue of Emperor Marcus
Aurelius these two big sculptures are
replicas of the ancient Greek originals
and there's the beautiful Santa Maria
Basilica in Araceli these different eras
conduct a dialogue with each other and
that's what makes this city so
extraordinary just a stone's throw away
is the Roman Forum
it was the centerpiece of ancient Rome
and today a key area for excavation the
forum gives an idea of what life was
like in Rome in the days of Julius
Caesar and Augustus
Roma paribas nishita modere Rome would
like to be both in ancient and the
modern sea but whenever we start digging
we find a Roman villa or a capital we
just have to accept all of Rome being a
museum also it can only adapt to modern
times in a limited way one of the
advantages of driving through Rome on a
Vespa is that it's easy to escape the
stressful city traffic the genicular
Hill offers a welcome Haven and the best
views of the city
jornatha 50 calls after a hard day's
work
we locals from Rome like to come here
and relax and on Sundays we visit the
many parks you can see from up here so
back there we see the low-lying dome
that's the Dome of the Pantheon which is
about 2,000 years old is the white
church with the two towers
that's Trinity de Monte which stands
above the Spanish Steps
and there's the Villa Medici the very
center of Rome is largely off-limits to
cars but not to the Vespa until we reach
the pedestrian zones and then even we
have to proceed on foot
here we find the trevi fountain which is
especially popular with tourists very
nice city to walk around it's great to
go shopping here and see the fountain
everyone's got to understand the roots
of Christian culture and learn about
classical antiquity all the major sites
are very busy Valerio van AZ advises
going to see them early in the morning
or late in the evening the most
beautiful woman of the 1960s Anita
Ekberg bathed in this fountain with my
cello master I mean looking on in
Federico Fellini's movie la dolce vita
it was filmed here at this fountain in
this water it always reminds visitors of
the film Shiva
at the end of the day Valerio Venezia
along with many other locals heads to
piazza navona here he enjoys an aperitif
with his wife
but if your significant aperitif means
the working day has ended people meet
with their friends eat a snack bring
something and then go home to make
dinner
siddhappa see vodkas fettuccine after
just one day of riding around Rome on a
Vespa it's clear we'd need many more if
we wanted to see all of this beautiful
city